good morning Hank it's Tuesday if you
are watching this video that means that
I have had a baby birthed through the
sweat of my brow and the effort of my
epic whines what's that Sara did the
birthing what was my role then Oh
apparently Hank I told her to push real
American heroes telling their partners
when to push although actually the
doctor gives the instruction and then I
just kind of reinforce it so yeah I'm
not really the hero of this story Hank
also I just turned the birth of my baby
into a beer commercial
right so Sara actually had the baby but
I am going to help with diaper changes
and many other tasks Hank when Henry was
born I only took a couple weeks off in
fact I went on my first work trip when
he was nine days old this time I am
going to take quite a bit more time away
not just from vlogbrothers but also from
writing and traveling and from my
careers as an amateur historian trivia
buff and of course most importantly
semi-professional FIFA players however
Hank in this absence I will be
exceedingly present for instance there
will be a crash course US history video
every single Thursday and a Mental Floss
video every Wednesday and the Swindon
Town moodily poopers will play every
Monday Wednesday and Friday as they
continue their heroic domination of
League One this is possible because
everyone in the office has worked
extremely hard to get way ahead for the
baby so thank you to Stan and Mark and
Danica and Meredith for being awesome
okay there are links to all these things
on screen and in the video info below so
really I will not be leaving you at all
past me will just be visiting present
you it's essentially the same stories
Back to the Future 3 also every Tuesday
there will be a John video just like
always on this very youtube channel
except where usually the role of John is
played by me it will be played by other
people like Hannah Hart and grace Helbig
and Craig wheezywaiter which is his real
last name and my secret sister Maureen
Johnson not to mention too nerd Factor
winners and now Hank a quick visit from
future me to current you to give you a
baby update tie everything is good baby
and mother are healthy and beautiful and
wonderful and were exhausted and high
okay all right and current me is going
to make a prediction about future me
that guy looks tired I'm a psychic
nerdfighters thank you as always for
making this community exist and for
making it such a wonderful part of my
life and also for letting me briefly
step away to be a full-time dad dftba
Hank I will see you on Friday